nos soignants sont en souffrance et
depuis plus de deux ans ça fait presque
trois ans que nous dénonçons des
conditions de travail déplorables à
l'hôpital et là on serait en train de
faire croire au pays que c'est nous qui
mettons en danger la population et ça
c'est pas entendable
[Musique]
c'est une décision complètement
désastreuse que le ministère a appris et
de ministres a pris ne soigne en un peu
plus sur le terrain nous avons passé
déjà un été dans des conditions très
particulières il manquait des effectifs
partout et donc ça va faire 4 avril et
les conditions de travail de douze
salariés
[Musique]
illégale certains salariés déjà qu'ils
ont commencé à à partir certains
salariés ont démissionné d'autres sont
mis en disponibilité tellement les
conditions de travail étaient
déplorables et tellement cette loi les
mettez en souffrance nous travaillons à
flux tendu tout le temps et là nous
allons travailler deux fois plus à flux
tendu
[Musique]